[Music]
that house on the hill just passed the
bill which seems like a big deal steel
still the media has decided it's been a
bad year for Trump see as the year ends
the hacks must splice together their
annual scorecards and yes they confirm
Trump did badly well except for Isis
getting rid of Isis that's a good thing
we destroyed modern-day Nazis but other
than that it was a bad year for Trump
except for the judges Gorsuch and all
those other strong appointments but
anyway terrible year for Trump except
for the economy and stock markets on
fire consumer confidence is soaring but
beyond that it has been awful except for
the new energy policy the approved
pipeline the new drilling the spread of
fracking gas prices flat as a pancake
but I'm telling you it's still a bad
year I'd hate to be Trump he's got no
singular achievements well okay there is
that tax bill which granted has been
improved since its first draft but it's
just been a lousy year except for the
improved relations with China and Russia
India the Saudis Israel but it's really
been a downer for Donny boy did I leave
anything out aside from deregulation
ditching the Accords repealing the
mandate oh and also driving M&M nuts
that's kind of Awesome so what's the
lesson from Trump's bad year that when
compiling your year-end condom condom
nations of Donald Trump it's a lot
harder than it looks
what started out as evil was that
downgraded to incompetent and now looks
pretty damn effective
no wonder the media looks so sad which
has now been downgraded to miserable all
right interesting little fact I learned
today data right after I they are
actually doing a revote of the bill
tomorrow why would they revote it's just
a technical glitch really because there
are three provisions in the GOP tax bill
that the Senate can't have voted up
anyway basically they just have to
realign the bills and it's a technical
thing there's no problem the tax bill
they get the bills in line yeah that's
all alright big deal I think it is a big
deal this is something
the president's been working really hard
on he's been around the clock and
talking to constituents and trying to
get support for this there really were
anxious to make sure to get some kind of
good legislative accomplishment prior to
the close of the year especially with
Christmas and whatnot so this to me I
think cannot I can only be viewed as a
positive
it's definitely steps in the right
direction and he seems to have been able
to coalesce some good broad-based
support even from people who haven't
traditionally supported him or his
legislation in the past so in that sense
yes and it's also important because it's
one of the main campaign you know
promises that he made when he went
across this country to try to engender
support for his movement for the working
men and women that he said we're left
behind to say listen to me I will give
you relief you will feel feel it you
will see it and it will be something
that's tangible for your families Jessie
I'm gonna play you some sound from Nancy
Pelosi and I'd like you to yes because
it's the one thing you hate more than
speed metal it's a close call let's roll
what she felt about the bill this is the
worst bill to ever come to the floor of
the house with stiff competition for
what some of the things they've tried to
do the worst bill in history Jessie
they're all the Republic except for Bill
Clinton right that's true they love him
migrate a few weeks ago on the universe
of the election I gave him a B+ on
domestic policy now with the tax bill
I'm going to a - imagine what he'd be
doing if the media wasn't 90% negative
the big headwind then you don't grade on
a curve I do not I do not only with
myself yeah so economic optimism right
now is through the roof 5,000 point gain
in the Dow for the major that's historic
and I think because finally America is
getting over the Great Recession
hangover so Trump is like the Gatorade
and the bacon egg and cheese that we
need after a hangover and it's working
and I want to try your little concepts
now you always say what specifically has
Trump done to change your actual life
well here's an example I think a third
of Americans have 401ks and the average
401k has about $100,000 in it just in
the first year alone the Trump economy
would have made you an extra 25 thousand
dollars for your 401k
that's a lot of money not only that jobs
are up wages are up slightly gas prices
as you say are flat and home ownership
is up to so just safety and security
there were not Kim bringing in all these
risky refugees the ISIS caliphates
destroyed the border crossings are down
in ms-13 prosecutions are up 89 percent
and then the social issues with the
liberals love to talk about gay marriage
is still legal abortion is still legal
medical marijuana recreational marijuana
the states have that had that still have
that so the Trump self you know
derangement syndrome I believe is
self-inflicted all the the fear and
loathing that the media pumps up is a
scam in order to keep his poll numbers
down and to help the Democrats win the
midterms so if you just look around and
feel around that Trump has been good for
America and Americans not bad well on a
vast majority are gonna get a tax break
that must destroy you inside oh yeah it
kills me I'm sorry
I'm sorry this is so ridiculous I have
no idea even how to listen with you guys
anyways I know the feeling with you
believable the way you put lipstick on a
pig
it's unbelievable that's a great line
that one because I mean if you I mean
let's let's just not view what Juan
Williams has to say let's think about
what the American people to percent
approval for Donald Trump at the end of
his age you don't have to like it you
don't want to hear that oh I got a kid
here how about the tight spill Greg 55%
of Americans oppose it sixty six percent
say it's helping only because they well
because the media has distorted oh yeah
that's majority are getting tax breaks I
mean you argue that because of you know
what you are counting crumbs while the
cake is going to the one-percent $500
you say oh gee would what's wrong with
you is when you're rich enjoy your bums
little people little people just eat up
and celebrate our dear leader Donald won
500 bucks is zero get out of this they
got crawl let me tell ya that's a little
your argument just take the whole games
I can't believe this at least they
at least you want people get they've
been robbing us long years finally the
intro lawyers brought in Republicans to
give him some of their hard-earned money
back and you don't want them to have it
your condescending attitude towards
American people let me pick on kimberly
guilfoyle because Kimberly and you said
Donald Trump said to the American people
I'm never gonna forget you I'm standing
up for the forgotten man and woman in
this country that working-class people
that's what I said oh and guess what
what a populist bill it is a huge
failure even by that standard of mind
you can say that all you are just making
stuff up okay sometimes yes but the fact
of the matter is it does provide
economic relief and tax cuts for the
majority of middle-class families so
here's the thing they're actually gonna
get this maybe even early part of next
year be able to feel some of this
benefit and then it's gonna be tangible
and then you're gonna see the numbers go
up in the poll if he was worried about
polling and if he thought it was so
determinative then he would have thought
that he was never gonna win the
presidency he's doing this because the
right thing to do him because he
promised it he has integrity and he
cares about making an economic way
record numbers look at the Dow already
five family hey Obama better in his
first year in terms of the stock
market's performance Obama did better
last year in terms of job creation than
Trump has done this year and here's
something from Nancy Pelosi Jesse's
favorite lot of credit 83% of the
benefits of this tax will go to the top
one percent in fact 60% one go to this
what you call from might look like a
crumb from your lofty perch over here 10
million Airwalk Williams that's lets you
real hardworking Americans it's a little
bit more money in their pocket
their money Oh yours that's why it's
going to the mill operations by the way
from white why are you so worried about
them getting it back that's why the
government still needs it don't care
that the rich get every yeah we're evil
I get it they pay all the taxes rich
Peter there's a tax cut they get to then
proportionally keep money in here but
first I want to get back to the the that
is true yeah the difficulty the media
has in framing their year-end stories
because of the emotion versus the
reality this is a Sarah Sanders going
over the achievements today nearly 1.7
million new jobs have been created and
the unemployment rate has fallen to 4.1
percent the lowest rate in 17 years the
stock market reached a record high more
than 60 times we finally set up our
nation on a path to not only energy
independence but energy dominance we've
seen the lowest level of illegal border
crossings on record Justice Gorsuch was
confirmed to the Supreme Court in this
evening
hopefully upon passage of the tax cuts
and Jobs Act the president will have
delivered the most significant tax cut
in the history of the nation and
repealed the Obamacare individual
mandate so Dana a person may not like
any of those things but those things
happened so I think you're seeing in
headlines this is my theory that people
are shifting away from awful - well
alright better-than-expected guy
actually got some stuff done which is
really hard for people to do I think I
think this she makes a compelling
closing argument there yeah you could do
it with a little more joy yeah they have
a good story to tell yeah but there is
something strange about the public's
mood mmm writ large and what's actually
happening on the ground I actually think
that if you were to take this back to
the fight between establishment
Republicans and the new Trump
Republicans and actually all those
things that you listed if you're a
traditional Republican you're looking at
that and you're like oh pretty good
that's so I think that the
so now changes that happen sort of in a
9th month or 8th to 9th month of August
and September have changed things in
terms of I guess tone and demeanor this
is an interesting which I think could up
but there is there's this lag part and
the other thing is there's something the
firing of James Comey which leads to the
Special Counsel which leads to everyday
talking about Russia I think that is
something that I think is a drag on
their ability to tell the other story
with joy yeah but it would say what
you're talking about there's an
interesting lag between what I hate the
phrases establishment Republicans and
the pro-trump repeal that's how we
define it yeah but you have people we
have there's a feud going on a National
Review right now between you know
Charles cook and the Jennifer Reubens
and David Frum zuv the world over this
because the hey Kim believed for Trump
is so strong that they can't actually
modify just a little bit and see that
they were there for a lot of these
things that he got done right because
they have just an essentially you know
an inherent bias in terms of they
dislike the individual regardless of
what they have to proffer right now you
have to be able to separate that
separate you know the sender from what
you're actually receiving yes look at
the tangible benefits of it but I've
actually seen besides a few kind of like
outliers more of you know a coalition
supporting the tax benefits and what the
president is trying to do so I find that
a little bit more encouraging just one
thing on that since I was so calm
earlier and just one point earlier in
the year you had the fights between Ryan
and Trump they're like fire so today
what happened on the house tax bill you
had President Trump's number one agenda
from his campaign and for the first year
of his presidency meet up with Paul
Ryan's lifelong career goal and they
actually get it done in that first year
and that is something that they can go
home and talk about but the Democrats
are going to go home and talk about it
to imagine imagine the 2018 elections
because every Republican either the
establishment Republican or people who
have shifted Gregory gutfeld to become
Trump Republicans they're all tied to
Trump now and with this tax bill every
Democrat running next year 2018 is going
to
oh you passed this bill for the rich oh
I love that you didn't say guess what
their run against the tax bill I think
it's a loser because if you look at the
polling because you know you like to
cite the polling right for the first
time in over a decade of majority say
the economy is good or excellent and a
historic record now say the economy will
improve the next year you separate their
feelings for Trump and their feelings
from the economy things are good I gotta
go you guys gotta help a person before
you ask for their vote hey wages and
jobs are up